la consulta popular que se desarrolla
este domingo en mexico se ha llevado a
cabo sin incidentes pero con muy poca
afluencia a decir de los funcionarios de
casilla de algunas de aquí de la ciudad
de mexico son 57 mil las que se han
instalado en todo el país el presidente
de lópez obrador que se encuentra en
nayarit declinó hacer comentarios al
respecto dijo que está ocupado en la
labor de su gira pero hay que recordar
que en días recientes cuestionó al
instituto nacional electoral porque dijo
no le dio la difusión requerida a esta
consulta y no instaló las casillas
suficientes a esto el presidente del
instituto electoral lorenzo córdova ha
dicho que se desplegó a una buena
cantidad de funcionarios y que si se le
dio la promoción requerida consideró
incluso que este ejercicio
independientemente de la participación y
los resultados ya es histórico en
términos de participación ciudadana la
jefa de gobierno claudia sheinbaum ya
acudió a emitir su voto y llamó a la
población a participar
hasta las 22 horas cuando se den a
conocer los resultados de este ejercicio
democrático en méxico